as a drummer you're conducting not only
the orchestra that is the band on stage
but the orchestra that are the people in
the audience that audience relationship
was a driving factor why I pursued music
saviem and why gladly spent my time as a
broke musicians but that's not
sustainable
we need artists we need artists when I
discovered blotching technologies it
dawned on me that this could empower
artists to continue to share their
creativity with the world which is in a
valuable human resource I played my
first paying gig at age 14 I became so
obsessed with playing drums and taking
as many gigs as I could if I had my soul
fed my it's kind of cliche to say that
but fed my creative spirit I was behind
that drum kit on various stages all over
the world chose where the applause from
the audience
drowned out my thoughts I was signed to
an independent label and I'm getting
millions of stream on digital
distribution platforms I felt that I had
made it and yet I was still struggling
to make ends meet where the money is for
artists is in live performances but when
it comes to event ticketing there's
still a lot of unnecessary middlemen we
often call them represents CalPERS or
touts these people buy up roughly 60% of
tickets and then charge these exorbitant
markups and sometimes unsuspecting fans
show up at the door of the venue and
they can't get in it's a fake ticket so
it's a major problem
just as the internet changed the way we
communicate blockchain is going to
change the way we transact the first
time in human history there's this
technology that shackles the brokers and
scalpers blockchain allows for direct
transactions between the artist and the
fan and the fan knows that the ticket is
verified and authentic and the money
will go directly into the pocket of that
artist they're not adding any value get
out of the way
the fundamental design of blockchain is
you have a peer-to-peer network so I can
do this transaction directly with you
and trust that it's real and you know
what I'm excited to go see the concert
the blockchain is open transparent and
mutable anyone can go to a website and
see the transactions happen whereby it's
incredibly hard to change a transaction
once it has occurred transparency
creates trust trusts forms the basis of
community the real human truth about
blockchain this is not just about
changing the way we transact money it's
about leveraging the technology shared
record of truth to establish trust
between people companies or even nations
and exchange what we value which is the
whole point of a community the human
experience is tribal and live
experiences cannot be digitally
replicated when the music hits you
that's something very real and visceral
and non digital it is just an incredible
feeling
[Music]
music is inextricably a part of who I am
because when it all comes crumbling down
we'll still have song and dance around
the fire and we're still gonna tell
stories it's part of the human
experience and without it we'd just be a
bunch of ones and zeros
[Music]